COLT MCANLIS: Google
Cloud Next 2017
hosted a huge number of talks
detailing the future of Cloud.
If you didn't get a chance
to catch the session,
Saving Money on
Compute Engine, then
stay tuned, because
here's the recap.
The pricing philosophy
for Compute Engine
is guided by three concepts--
RETO MEIER: Simplicity,
flexibility, and fairness.
We aim to make pricing
as simple as we can
by offering
preconfigured products,
like N1 standard, that
can be easily customized
for your workload.
Similarly, we know that at its
essence a VM is CPUs and RAM.
So another way we keep
things simple and transparent
is by not bundling
other components that
create opaque skews that
hide the true costs.
COLT MCANLIS: In
terms of flexibility,
we focus on the concepts
of pay for what you use
and buy only what you need.
All clouds are pay as you use.
But the way you count usage
matters a lot in practice.
In GCE, we've had per
minute billing since day one
because at Google we
understand that workloads
don't come in hour long chunks.
We also offer custom
machine types,
including the ability to
efficiently schedule jobs
and VMs of any size.
A little over a year after
we launched this feature,
over 20% of all Compute
Engine workloads
are using custom machine
types and customers
are saving an average of
19% from this feature alone.
RETO MEIER: When you use
our VMs consistently it's
more efficient for us.
And we give those
savings back to you
through sustained use discounts.
You still maintain
all the flexibility
of an on-demand cloud.
Start and stop instances
in whatever way
makes sense to your workload.
And change your usage
pattern whenever you need.
We'll give you the best discount
that your usage qualifies
for automatically.
For pre-defined
instances, we use
a concept called
inferred instances
to calculate the biggest
savings that we can.
When we introduced
custom machine types,
we generalized this
model so it works
even with the thousands
of possible instance
shapes that you
can have with CMT.
COLT MCANLIS: If the
graph on the right
is a picture of how
you actually ran
a series of five different VMs
of the same size and shape,
it doesn't look like you ran
any of them for very long.
Now, see, what we do here is
combine similar VMs over time,
as shown in the middle
picture, where we reinterpret
those same five VMs as if they
were three longer running VMs.
When you look at those as
a percentage of the month,
you'll get the max
discount on one,
a healthy discount
on the second,
and the first tier of
discount on the third.
RETO MEIER: And with
committed use discounts,
you can get our best
discount levels in exchange
for telling us which
resources you're guaranteeing
to use for the long-term.
On predefined types, you can
get a 37% discount on one year
commitments and a 55%
discount on three years.
For custom machine types,
the discounts are 40 and 57%
respectively.
COLT MCANLIS: With our
right sizing features,
you can focus on bringing
your workload to the cloud.
And once it's running, we'll
watch your CPU and memory
utilization and give
you recommendations
to help reduce costs.
COLT MCANLIS: And by
using preemptible VMs,
a class of super
low cost VMs that
are optimized for short-term
use, you can save up to 80%
off the list prices.
Preemptible VMs are ideal for
fault tolerant, large scale
workloads that can handle
single workers occasionally
failing or disappearing.
COLT MCANLIS: And finally,
there's our autoscaler.
Because we don't
need pre-warming,
you don't have to
pay for idle time
while VMs are just
sitting around.
Similarly, because we can
boot VMs in about 30 seconds
and scale down in
60 seconds later,
you're not paying for
extra boot or idle time.
RETO MEIER: To hear
some real examples
of how customers spend
money in the cloud
and how the Google pricing
philosophy and features
described here can help
you save more money,
check out the full session
on the Google Cloud YouTube
channel.
COLT MCANLIS: And
for more information
on saving money
with Compute Engine,
check out the full
talk on YouTube.
If you're looking for more
recaps on great Next content,
make sure to check out
the rest of our playlist.
And don't forget the Next
world tour coming soon
to a city near you.